[Music]
hey y'all it's matinee 76 yeah I can't
remember what movies we saw you have to
remind me on this one what was yeah
again we didn't go to the theatre again
this week cuz again nothing really
started to go wrong flag well that to
you but like I said nothing really
started either you know um we should go
this coming week because I think quiet
place to starts and there was one other
thing that was maybe starting maybe
blood shot or something yeah
but this week we watch stuff on Netflix
and shudder like we usually do when
there's not enough stuff playing in the
theater so the first one that we're
gonna talk about seems to be very
popular on Netflix that just got added
like a week or two ago this is Spencer
confidential yeah one with Mark Wahlberg
yeah and it was directed by Peter Berg
and I actually didn't know this and I
haven't seen any of the other ones but
this is actually their fifth
collaboration they've made four movies
together previous to this Peter Berg is
also an actor I actually when I saw his
picture I was like oh I recognized him I
can't remember what movies but I've seen
him in a whole bunch of movies but he
directs movies as well and this is the
fifth one that he's done I don't know
this is a good movie yeah most people
seem to like some of their other
collaborations like lone survivor a lot
of reviewers talked about how much they
liked that one
Deepwater Horizon Patriots day most
people said they did one called mile 22
which wasn't so good but most of the
other ones got pretty you know got
pretty good reviews and stuff yeah what
this one is it's almost kind of like a
like a almost like an 80s action buddy
throwback flick you're talking about
something kind of like Beverly Hills Cop
48 hours Lethal Weapon it's in that
genre and it was good I liked it I did
too i enjoyed this much more than I
thought I was going to now as I said I
haven't seen the the other movies that
they've made together but apparently
those were mostly like action-oriented
or more like based on true story type of
stuff whereas this one is kind of more a
comedy like a action buddy cop comedy it
has like action and it has violence and
it's stuff like that too but it really
sorry I didn't mean you have to it
really reminded me of their videos cop
mark Mark Wahlberg play
and Axel Foley but his own you know I
mean fish-out-of-water cop story it
reminded our spy but I will say and
maybe this is a bold statement but I
actually liked this a bit better than 48
hours because when we brie watched 48
hours the other day I had forgotten how
unlikable know his character yeah that
was part of that movie I liked what 48
hours revisiting it the beginning one
quarter that movie was kind of stale
yeah but when Eddy joined up and then
they started doing this yeah I've read
some lightly this one the best thing
about this one I think and this is
another thing that I didn't really
realize when I was watching it now this
is based on a novel character repeating
novel character that was I believe the
novel's first started to come out in the
70s like 1974 by a guy called Robert B
Parker and then after he died a guy
called ace Atkins took over from hit for
him now this character has also been the
basis he's been like 50 books he was
also the basis for you remember that
show from the 80s that was on ABC I
think it was called Spenser for hire
late about a private eye that's the same
character okay as as Mark Wahlberg is
playing in there alright so they're
bringing that back
yeah sort of and so this is very very
loosely based on I never saw that so I
didn't I didn't even catch that I mean I
had heard of that show but I don't think
I ever saw it so this is loosely based
on one of the Spenser novels which is
called Wonderland I haven't read that
book but I from what I can gather from
other sources and other people that have
read the book this is not very similar
it has kind of like a similar structure
but a lot of the characters are
different and the comedic tone is
different and things like that but it
does seem like Netflix if this is
successful and it looks like it's been
the number one on Netflix at least the
last few days that I've checked it seems
like they're trying to start their own
kind of homegrown franchise out of these
books because there are a lot of them
and the guy that's writing the more
recent ones is still writing them like
they're still coming out it was fast
paced the acting was great in it real
good heads good action real good story
likeable characters is kind of in
classic tale it's come yes it's very
much like an 80s buddy combo which seems
to be like people that I mean it seems
to be getting it depends on where you
look at the reviews it seemed like
google users that seemed like it was 93
percent like it seemed like Rotten
Tomatoes was more like half in half or
you know what or whatever IMDB was like
half and a half it did seem like really
the only criticism that people were
leveling at it was well it's not really
anything new it's like you know it's a
buddy cop thing and it you know Hughes
to a lot of the tropes of that genre
that's good but in a way like that did
not bother me in the slightest even
though yes it's not doing anything
earth-shattering yes it's not I mean I
think the best thing about it is Mark
Wahlberg and his interactions with the
guy that becomes his sidekick who's
played by his name is Hawke and the
movie and he's played by Winston Duke
who was in black panther obviously and
he was also the dad and us and he was
[ __ ] fantastic in that and the
character that he plays in this is so
funny and the two of them are like
really they have like really good like
comedic timing and like really good
comedic chemistry together to me he's
he's the white Axel Foley he's an ex-con
ex-cop private investigator
yeah and he's he's a badass he's smart
but he's funny he wins he loses you know
even though Eddie Murphy always won well
no I guess he he did kind of this a
little bit yeah but you know you gotta
lose sometimes otherwise no space that
same genre it's that same kind of
feel-good
action-adventure cop buddy type stuff
it's just that's the genre I think they
just nailed yeah it's just this is this
is really just a great movie to you know
it's like it's a Friday night you don't
have anything going on you're drinkin
you order a pizza
you just you know put this movie on and
it's just fun it's just a fun like all
the characters are funny
nothing's pissing you off grossing you
out nothing scaring you it's just
interesting characters and [ __ ] happen
yeah and there's just like funny lot and
and really some of the comedic stuff
like it's not really really like
over-the-top zany or anything like that
I feel like a lot of the comedy is kind
of realistic like yeah like realistic
a little bit understated but in a way I
think that makes it work better yes what
a way constantly back to the Eddie
Murphy Eddie Murphy movies Eddie Murphy
cop movies where you could tell that
Murphy was kind of ad-libbing yeah stuff
that it felt very natural the [ __ ]
that's happened yeah a lot of it some of
it of course is clownish like his
ex-wife or his ex-girlfriend yeah they
met was xyc I think it was his
girlfriend
I don't think they said they were
married I can't remember she was funny
there she's very abrasive like in a very
Boston type of way and this is a very
very Boston movie I'm in Boston five
years I'm tell you that this is a very
Boston I mean as it would because that's
where Mark Wahlberg is from so he's he
kind of made a career on playing these
types of characters that come from this
neighborhood so but a lot of it Alan
Arkin is in this too playing Mark
Wahlberg playing Spencer
I guess alan arkin 'he's character he
calls him Henry at first I thought it
was his dad but it's not his dad I felt
like it was you know like Rocky and you
know Paulie or whatever I thought it was
that kind of situation where because
Henry like runs a boxing gym or a UFC
gym or something like that which is
where Hawk comes from and they you know
he let Hawk move into the house wall all
kinds of funny [ __ ] answer was
imprisoned
now Spencer was a cop but then he goes
to prison but for a good reason
you know what I mean like he is ESPO
that yeah I'm not really gonna say like
what the reason was but it was like a
justified reason yeah and then nothing
is about the movies that I had a really
good villain and I don't want to spoil
that because you don't know the villain
is until later on yeah cuz there's kind
of like he's a real likable kind of
villainy he's kind of sympathetic in a
certain way you know ii mean he just has
a different motivation and you know
trying to protect a bunch of bad cops
yeah it's a it's a cop corruption is
movie he's not a good guy but most these
guys aren't really good guys it's just
you just have to see the movie and as I
said you know as I was saying before I
lot of the humor that I liked about it
other than like the character of his
ex-girlfriend
whoo yeah I can see how some people make
oh she's like just loud and abrasive
instead of like that but I thought she
was a delight like especially talking
about poodles coming at her ass and
stuff like that yeah but probably my
favorite character in this though was
Winston Dukes character of hog just
because he was like it's a totally
different character than he played in us
he's just like this big strong silent
type he's kind of like a health nut he's
like an up-and-coming like UFC fighter
or what or a boxer or whatever and he
doesn't talk a lot but there does seem
like a lot of kind of depth going on and
one of my favorite scenes in it was when
went later on when they said like one of
the villains or somebody that they were
like going after and he said that he had
killed a cat and so he had killed people
and [ __ ] - yeah but then Hawkes
characters like he killed a cat yeah
like yeah and he's like that was like
right exactly yeah yeah this was
actually like a real like I said it's
been it seems like it's getting kind of
mixed reviews in some venues there's
like something some really good ones
like like I said Google reviews that
seem like 93 percent positive this is
just it really it's not reinventing the
wheel it's not anything like that if you
like 80s buddy cop action comedy type
movies yeah and you like Mark Wahlberg
you liked the other movies that he did
with Peter Berg then I see no reason why
you wouldn't like this one like I said
it's not super original or anything like
that but it's just a lot of fun the
characters are fun the interactions are
fun you know we just say something
similar to that I'm gonna say it's a
movie of the genre it did hit the mark
yeah it's what it's what them they
actually achieved what they tried to do
they made a movie that if you like say
like Beverly Hills Cop or lethal weapons
that type of classic cop movie it's a
it's a modern version of that but they
didn't go outside the genre yeah it's a
fresher take on that it's a more modern
the way it looks you know of course but
it still kind of had that nostalgic for
me that kind of nostalgic movie movie
feeling I felt like I was watching an
old movie that had seen before in a way
yeah or a movie that had seen many times
already yeah but that's like a good
things not like it was like comforting
like yeah you know like a familiar I did
I didn't see certain things coming there
you know I didn't know what was
happening I just felt very comfortable
in the movie because I understand I
understood the vibe and the genre
immediately
yeah with your Dalek okay yeah yeah I
know this one yeah you know it's like
that and you guys I mean you guys know
that um you know we we have kind of
different taste in movies but usually
you can tell if he's gonna like a movie
because he'll put his tablet down and
like actually start paying attention I
think in the first five or 10 minutes
and this movie I I kind of put it on and
then he came in and he kind of picked
his tablet up but then he's like oh yeah
II just watched it so start it which it
usually doesn't happen he was speaking
my language yeah you know and and I
would say maybe one out of five movies
speaks my language - yeah
the ones that we're watching yeah I
think the ones that we don't watch I
think it's maybe one out of 50 yeah I
mean I wouldn't really know cuz we don't
want to watch him but I'm just so glad
yeah yeah you know what I mean you know
I'm not the only one you know I got you
know I got people on Instagram and
Facebook that go yeah we got the same
taste in movies know exactly you're
talking about yeah and you know so I'm
not the only one you know that's like
this just yes I don't necessarily think
it's a generational thing because
there's younger guys that like the exact
same movies that I like and like the new
ones in the old ones yeah it's I don't
think it's an age thing I don't get I
think it's just like a personality type
thing I think I'll watch pretty much
anything but you know and it's pretty
obvious to me you know as old as I am as
experienced as I am men and women are
different men look men kind of tell
stories a different way and they like
being told stories a different way than
women do men like to get right to it you
know I mean yeah they'll jump and kind
of jump tell you what kind of move it's
gonna be then they back up and tell you
the movie so and that's kind of like
that's how guys tell stories and for me
the movies that I like well the end
ending that I just swung time yeah
it doesn't have to do it you're like
because I have to know if I'm gonna like
it or exactly exactly yeah but they
don't have to do it that way
it's just like guys are learning most
guys and I've noticed this as other
dudes they're waiting for certain cues
to happen and then they go okay I gotta
see this that's yeah yeah women seem to
have that a little more forgiveness
they'll wait around and watch something
and they'll watch it for twenty or
thirty minutes before they even know
what the movies about oh yeah I don't
mind doing that mo got most guys won't
tolerate it
I mean I can very very rarely like I'll
put on a movie and like after five or
ten minutes I'm like man I'll think this
is gonna get any better that doesn't
usually happen usually if I start
watching something I know that I at
least have some kind of passing interest
in it so I'll usually see it through to
the end unless it really really bores me
or really really misses me off that
doesn't usually happen because I usually
like to give things a chance sometimes
you know even if something's like in the
beginning like it'll get really good at
the end so I'm like waiting to see what
happen
so yeah I'm like much more women are
more forgiving I'm more patient I'm more
forgiving and I'm more like open to
other people's ideas other people's
visions it's like maybe I wouldn't have
necessarily done it like that but it's
like yeah I see where you were going
with that and I think it was successful
from your point of view even though
that's not how I would have made yeah
and I think I think kind of like most
guys their minds are kind of like on
Rails it's kind of like on track I guess
yeah I've noticed that actually we
expect the information to come notice
that's the way we are yeah it's very
linear and and given I mean we expect
things to be given to us in a certain
order or the right way yeah or you know
what I mean if it starts like I said I
call it my 1015 minute rule yeah if I
don't know what the [ __ ] going on in
10 or 15 minutes or I don't give a [ __ ]
in 10 or 15 minutes then I'm not going
care yeah that's just and and that and
and that rule has held up with me that
if I start paying attention to it later
I still don't like it anymore it has to
catch me early yeah and there's and I
can't describe it but other guys know
what I'm talking about yeah
there's something about the way the
story is told I remember
reading somewhere I don't remember where
I read this you know but I remember
somewhere that that men's brains are
like a sledgehammer whereas women's
brains are like a Swiss Army knife
probably yeah yeah I would think so I
don't know how true cuz like I said any
kind of generalizations it's like
obviously there's outliers and
everyone's not gonna be the same there's
hormonal differences but I have told him
I'm like my brain is like 47,000 tab
like Google tabs open yeah I guess I am
young young guy are 16 17 18 high
testosterone he's not gonna see things
the same way a guy in his 40s are gonna
see it yeah it's too different but
there's a lot a lot in common yeah I
mean like I can see from his point of
view just that you know see it that way
anymore
yep type of deal you know now you just
watch how their review products and [ __ ]
you know I mean you like one deal with
the [ __ ] you talking about anyway um
yeah their biology is a factor in this
I'll give a [ __ ] anybody says but I did
like this movie a lot actually I thought
I thought it was this one yeah I thought
it was a great time so even though yeah
it's kind of a little bit of guy movie
as a man warranted movie but but yeah I
don't see why why women enjoy it also I
had a lot of fun with it I thought it
was very funny I really liked you know
the character interactions between Mark
Wahlberg's character and what some Dukes
character that was probably my favorite
part also Eleanor feels great in it so
you know there's a lot there so actually
not not to shut it down because now I'm
now I'm on a roll there are some male
oriented movies that are classics even
among women like well yeah like alien 1
and 2 well yeah everybody agrees
everybody agrees that there's a great
[ __ ] grateful I don't care who you
are a great [ __ ] you can be you could
be a [ __ ] you can be from outer space
and you still have them with a realistic
heroine yeah hey you don't I mean that's
it's just realistic to me you know man
and she all the characters are realistic
they all seem like real lived in raw
people this whole thing about well you
have to identify with the characters I
identify with Ripley yeah yeah I mean
and I'm sure a woman can identify with a
male character yeah you know I can go
man I'd be [ __ ] if I was in her
she's oh man oh man thanks County you
know it's of course yeah so that's well
I doesn't have to be for a long time
like prior to you know maybe
60s or 70s I feel like a lot of main
characters in movies were men so if I
mean women going to movies you had to
relate to a man character because that's
kind of all there was it yeah fifties
movies the way they were written I mean
the women were just like [ __ ] bit
parts that's what I mean so it's like
you didn't have so women have always had
to relate to male characters because
that's for a long time that was the only
character that had any depth I think a
lot of times a female characters didn't
have any depth to it I think it was
mostly because what is what we've
watched his horror and sci-fi and it was
that was warranted towards young guys
yeah for the time but the really good
well-written ones like King Kong they
have female characters yeah ain't
calling it that was a [ __ ] bad-ass
foot although I will say on the flip
side of that I have found that horror
and sci-fi tended to be a lot more
progressive in that area yeah you know
and we're open to having you know female
uh you know characters like main
characters african-american main
characters and stuff like that and it
didn't happen on purpose I don't
budgetary and that's just what who they
had but yeah but sometimes I feel like
that is a genre since it's always been
not so much nowadays but you know since
it was always kind of a disreputable or
a younger person genre I feel like you
could get away with a lot more there was
a lot more open possibilities and stuff
so I feel like they broke a lot of
taboos yeah and the reason why I'm mad
Living Dead had a had a black lead is
because he was the best actor because he
was the best but it gave ya like a depth
that maybe didn't have like when I first
see this that old white dudes ass in
front of his wife yeah that with the
whole black and white diamond in a
context of the 60s that was like oh man
this movie isn't [ __ ] around this for
real
because that was I think that [ __ ]
asked to me too you know but he was but
but when when they threw the color mix
in the context of the 60s that that
movie knocked it out of the [ __ ] Park
it did and they didn't they didn't
[ __ ] fill out the paperwork the right
way I know and I'm like that made public
domain that's a shame lost is the only
the only criticism I can make is that
the female character in there Barbara
Barbara is totally [ __ ] useless I'm
she's in shock and everything and at
least they do have another female
character in the browser other what's
the moves more you know that are more
resourceful so that it's not just this
useless we're getting another subject
but still kind of Florida when I was a
kid Barbara scared me so I think that
that was a good character yeah maybe say
because I was like man that's creepy
what happened to her she's crazy Wow I
mean yeah I guess she's been shot shows
in Shaba she was a shock because of what
happened to her but her shock was like
disturbing me and tannin laughs yeah
well thirty that it made the whole thing
creepier yeah had this guy trying to
help this girl cheating really know
where she was saying random [ __ ] yeah
and you know when you're like 10 and you
don't know if that's a possibility or
not you just seeing it you're going home
some people would probably react that
way yeah so I guess I can't if she was
the only female character in the movie
then it might bother me more but since
there are like you said like the the
wife who actually does stand up to her
husband in a resume then it was and that
other that that other girl the Mater
chick the Maude chick remember yeah and
there's yes which would you call her
Maude [ __ ] no no it's just like a
regular like a regular chick she was
like the girlfriend of that young yeah
right yeah you know where they tried to
go out and get the gas and everything so
yeah so it's not as problematic in that
regard but yeah it's like yeah we went
up at this big long yeah well since
we're off on it tell ya you gonna say
anything problematic about [ __ ] about
night living no I just said I can see
how some people might see that as
manages because she's completely useless
if she was the only female character in
the movie then it would annoy me
I wish she's not you reading it yeah it
was it was it was that was the blueprint
that created the Walking Dead first of
all that created the whole zombie movie
genre with that still with us to this
day that first really awesome three
seasons of The Walking Dead would have
never happened with that that no no
definitely not um but I was gonna say
while we were on the topic of being off
topic
yeah if you guys have noticed we
rearranged the office yeah gonna have a
new so yeah so if you see like back
there in that back corner where that
black and grey bookshelf er that's where
the desk that we're sitting at used to
be so we moved it over here just so we
could have a bed
backdrop and we ordered two new chairs
yes so we're gonna like set up a little
studio back there live in two
bookshelves right lighting right and
we'll try to get the lighting right
we're just doing this kind of light and
getting rid of those old chairs because
those old chairs that have us down
scrunch and lie clear on down yeah we
ordered new triple chins and I don't
think that they're gonna be here for the
next episode because uncomfortable
chairs but yeah we got two matching
chairs and they're supposed to come like
next week sometime so probably for the
next movie retrospective they'll
probably we'll probably have them alive
it all set up by then but yeah so yeah
so Spencer confidential I'll definitely
get a pizza get a beer sit down and
watch it it's a lot of fun he's fun
you
all right the next one we're gonna talk
about is another new Netflix movie this
one comes from Spain and it is called
twin murders : The Silence of the White
City this is kind of like um one of
those sort of like baroque serial killer
but it's very much in the Silence of the
Lambs seven type of vein it reminded me
a little bit of this might be kind of
out there but it reminded me is slightly
just in its whole aesthetic and like the
whole like artistic like you know
aesthetic of it it reminded me of this
old kind of one of the more iconic
giallo films the house with the Laughing
windows it kind of reminded me a little
bit of that although it's not quite as
good as all of those comparisons imply I
will say that I did like this movie but
it was kind of a mixed bag so basically
it's set in this city called vitória in
Spain and the setup of the story is that
20 years ago in this city there was a
serial killer called the sleeper killer
and what he would do was he would pick
out like a random man and a woman and
then he would kill them and he would lay
them out in this particular thing they'd
both be naked and he put like these big
like sunflowers like over their genital
regions and make it look like they were
sleeping like he would like put their
hands together and stuff like that and
it seemed like he was sending some sort
of message altar for a long time he
couldn't figure out what it was now they
thought that they had caught this guy
and they put him in jail I think his
name was ignacio the guy that they
thought had did it had done it so he's
in jail but even though he's still in
jail these murders start again like 20
years later so they have this like
detective named unnai who is trying to
figure out if is if it's the same person
if Ignacio was not the guy that did it
the first time or if this is a copycat
or some other things like surrounding
that now I will say that much like
Silence of the Lambs where they show you
who Buffalo Bill is this one reveals the
killer about halfway through the movie
so you know who the killer is
the cops don't know so some of the
suspense is coming from them trying to
figure out who the killer is I'm not
gonna spoil who the killer is because I
wasn't expecting it like I saw some
reviews that said yeah they figured it
out but I had I didn't figure it out and
I was like oh [ __ ] it's that guy so you
don't I mean so a lot of the suspense
comes from that that said though there
was like I really liked some aspects of
this like the way it's shot is really
beautiful like all the buildings and
stuff that you know it's it's in Spain
and they film it's like medieval looking
city so like all the buildings and stuff
are really cool which is probably why it
reminded me of like an old Jala movie or
something and it and I liked sort of
like the baroque aspects of it with you
know the way that the victims are posed
and like this whole mythology behind it
like the serial killer you know which
they kind of slowly reveal over the
course of the movie like what message
that he's trying to send with the way
that he poses them and like what all the
symbolism is you know the way that he
kills the people is actually pretty
horrible where he just like has these
tube things and he like puts bees in
their mouths and like then puts gasoline
all over so the bees freak out and they
like sting you to death and [ __ ] like
that well no I'm just saying no because
they showed that pretty early on okay
they showed that pretty early on in the
in the movie but there was something
that kind of bothered me about it and I
couldn't put my finger on what it was
until like I read this other review of
it it almost seems like and I I think
this is based on a novel and the two
guys that wrote the screenplay have
written some other ones that were
apparently pretty popular in Spain and
stuff but I almost felt like this one
was trying to almost like hew to a
template you know what I mean
like it they're like okay well we saw
Silence of the Lambs so what happens
like this scene this scene this scene
and it's almost kind of like they were
trying to replicate that it's not
exactly like Silence of the Lambs but
the way it's structured like kind of
reminded me of that but it didn't so it
didn't have like a real like organic
flow like from scene to scene like this
happened and then this happened like in
a natural sort of way I have to agree it
almost seemed like okay this scene okay
well now it's time for this scene to
happen so we'll have these two
characters talking and figuring this
out so it almost said so in a like the
first time I was watching I'm like I
like this but the editing is there
something about the editing it's very
strange and I couldn't put my finger on
it and I think that's what it was that
it was almost kind of like the plot was
a little convoluted like a couple of
times when a character would come up and
they'd be talking and I'd be like okay
well wait who was this again and then I
was like oh yeah yeah that's right
because the backstory is like really
complex so you really have to kind of
like pay attention to who this person is
and why this person was doing that and
all this other kind of stuff so it took
me a while to kind of like catch the
wave of the movie because it almost
seemed like it was just going from B to
B to B yeah I was out of it by that
point without yeah I mean you missed
like the whole first half of that you
missed like the first whole half of the
movie which you can't really this is
definitely one that if you want to watch
it you really need to pay attention cuz
otherwise you were not gonna have the
slightest clue what is going on because
they're really really complicated I will
say this it looked like it was competent
shot yeah it's a beautiful one that
movie looked very good yeah the ending
had some really cool action horror
scenes in it yeah it's pretty violent
there's a lot of nudity yeah it was
pretty good
the scenes that they showed but I could
tell just by the way you know like you
said the flow of the way the scenes were
going us or medicine convoluted shape
here
it was it like I said it's a very very
convoluted story and there's a lot of
characters and there's a lot of stuff
going on I mean it's not too bad with
like the flashbacks and stuff there are
some flashbacks that show like you know
why the killer was doing this and who
this is in relation to the killer and
stuff it they did it wasn't too
egregious but if you didn't pay
attention to who all the characters were
I guess because it's very plot heavy so
you know and it's very visual so they
were kind of concentrating on that and
they didn't concentrate as much on the
characters so I feel like you didn't
really get a sense I mean and I who's
the main character who's like a serial
killer profiler detective or whatever
you know you find out that his you know
his pregnant wife was killed it you know
and all this other stuff so he's kind of
like just returning to work after a long
you know hiatus where he was like
getting over his grief but that's kind
of all you learn about him it's
he's not like a real in-depth they don't
give you a lot of in-depth you know
stuff into you know why he's doing what
he's doing why he's so into this case
and all this other kind of stuff so I
feel like they should have focused a
little bit more on fewer characters and
kind of given them a little more
dimension rather than cuz this is a very
like I said it's a very plot heavy movie
so the plot is kind of like dictating
what the characters do rather than the
other way around you know what I mean
which is something that which is why I
thought when I was thinking about it
that I thought the screenwriters were
maybe new with this because that seems
like something that amateur writers do
they let the plot dictate the characters
actions whereas the characters are
supposed to dictate what happens in the
plot you know what I mean so I kind of
got the feeling that it was like a
little bit reversed that said if you
like crime thrillers if you like Silence
of the Lambs if you like foreign
language this this has the actress I
think I can't report her name is but she
was in the orphanage and she's been like
a bunch of other stuff to orphanage she
should definitely see that because
that's a [ __ ] great movie so if you
like crime films especially like you
know spanish-language ones or you like
European crime thrillers you should
probably check it out but I mean I've
seen a lot better ones than this it's
not terrible but like I said it's kind
of a mixed bag if you watch it you'll
kind of see what I'm talking about where
it looks really good but it's a little
bit hard to follow and I you know I had
a hard time like keeping all the
characters straight and keeping the
backstory straight and some other things
too and there's like a little bit of
believability issues with like some of
the relationships within the characters
and why would the cops have been allowed
to work on this case when they were
emotionally involved and also their kind
of stuff it was a pain which maybe it
works different in Europe I don't know
but it's sort of like we're you know
whereas in in the u.s. at least and most
European countries - as far as I know if
you are you know related to somebody
who's like a victim in a murder for
example um they're gonna take you off
the case which I think they do all over
Europe as well so it does kind of seem
like maybe this is some of it was kind
of from the book so I don't really know
I've read the book but you know check it
out if you're into that kind of thing I
wouldn't go out of my way to watch it um
but it wasn't bad if you like that kind
of thing you know what I mean so you
know
you
okay the third movie we watched actually
came out in 2019 and toured it a bunch
of European horror festivals and whatnot
but just dropped on shudder the other
day this is called the room no not that
one it's not the top it was there one
another one this is another one this is
actually um it's in English
but I believe it was a French or Belgian
production or a French Belgian
co-production Olga Korea Kirilenko is in
it from she was in Quantum of Solace and
she was in Oblivion also so this has
like some kind of big stars in a CEM and
dances in it he was in revenge which is
also on shudder and which everybody
should check out if you like rape
revenge movies because that was really
excellent so yeah so this premiered at a
festival in Brussels and has kind of
been making the rounds and just got to
shutter this movie is a weird [ __ ]
movie
oh this is a head trip I liked this one
liked it too is frustrating though it is
but I can see why your freshmen and I
kind of like weak hit I want to I want
to spoil it because there's so much I
want to like talk about this movie but
it I can't boil it alright they buy this
house they're this married couple buys
this house it's in upstate New York or
it's supposed Raya and he finds this
weird ass he didn't know what it was at
first cuz it was a key yeah it was away
pieces and later on as he's tearing a
wall or moving to wallpaper he finds a
hidden door that goat and that key goes
to it and opens it up and it's just a
black room you can't see in there so
there's this [ __ ] hidden room and
it's got it's just this weird ass room
well I guess we could say they don't
know why or how it works there's wires
all throughout the walls you can go in
there and if you wish for something it
comes true there's got to be a thing
like if you can wish for money it'll
boom it'll make money yeah
if you wish for famous paintings it'll
make because that's what he did he was
rise light so flicker and then it'll be
there well this course gets him into a
lot of trouble and that's really what
this movies about the trouble that this
shit's causes yeah alright because I
don't want to spoil the rules you know I
mean of course you know if you have a
[ __ ] room that fulfills wishes you
know this could
be stipulations [ __ ] [ __ ] yes because
this is a horror movie yeah you know I
mean so you don't hand that that's what
I mean so I really really don't want to
spoken because I didn't know I mean all
I knew about the movie was that it was
about a couple that bought a house cuz
it says this on the little paragraph on
shudder it's a couple that buys a house
and they discover a room in the house
that grants wishes
that's all it tells you right and
they're trying to figure out what it is
you can wish for and man they they
you'll see this is just it's so it's
it's pissing me off because it's like
it's so hard to talk about without
spoiling I also kind of really
entertained just by watching them trying
to figure out what they could wish for
them what would happen yeah which anyway
right so that's the movie it's a good
movie I think it was frustrating to me
because some of the problems that this
room's caused I could have easily solved
well yeah but but they weren't solving
that problem easily because they
shouldn't understood by what by the
other wishes that they made what
happened I you know I mean I I'm my
hands are tied I can't really like I
said I was before we serve no I'm a
direct action [ __ ] some of this
[ __ ] that would have it on oh no no no
you know that may well see but that's
worth a conflict in the road this isn't
spoiling too much this this is where the
conflict in the movie arose because one
of the wishes that they made ended up
causing a conflict between the two of
them so if you if they had both been
just like yeah let's take care of that
issue then there wouldn't yeah it sounds
like and you can see where the conflict
arose from because there was like they
didn't really go a lot into the
backstory or a lot into like their
backstory but dude knew the dude knew
that you couldn't do that yeah this she
was kind of like emotionally you know
nobody no no you know this is how it's
gonna be I just said now this is too
dangerous and not taking care of that no
matter where she said yeah you know I
mean Chris and then the longer you let
that ride the worse that would have got
well the worse that the worse it did get
what they called it this is yeah woman
like I said it's a horror movie and it's
kind of like it reminded me of like a
really good like Twilight Zone episode
it's very much like the monkey's paw
that type of that type of thing where
you know you get granted three wishes
and they you know wish for somebody come
back from the dead or something like
that
but it's kind of like it took that
premise but then it goes in these really
kind of like messed up directions
because I didn't know like I said other
than the wish-granting room that's and
that it was a horror movie and it looks
like so we thought of it the same time
it looked like some kind of Tesla
technology it was a yes as soon as he
said Tesla well it wasn't magic it was
some kind of an old turn of the center
oh but I like that they didn't
technology go into that they didn't go
into it why somebody built the house
like that why the room could do that but
you didn't need it we come from the age
of Tesla yeah you didn't need it it was
just you know all it showed it and it
was just like you know that's why the
house is doing and they did have it
there is a plot thread where like the
guy is trying to figure out you know how
the rim does what it does but I like
that they just left it mystifying
because it's not important this the the
movie the whole theme of the movie is
you know I know nothing quite so toward
traitors be careful what you wish for
but it is kind of like that because it's
kind of going to the point where a while
everything that you wish for has
consequences that you maybe didn't
foresee yeah and so I feel like yeah
that's a lot of little details guys keep
yeah because at the end of the movie
then you makes yourself question what
was it you just watched I'm so yeah
because there's okay seem to be more to
the room and just wishing for physical
things there's other things it is almost
kind of like what is it a holodeck what
is it you don't know what you know
because you don't know how the room
works because a lot more yeah and that's
one of the reasons that I think it was
good that they didn't really tell you
how it worked
they I mean it the movie had rules they
thought they would knew what the rules
were though but but they may have been
wrong but they may have been wrong and
and that's good because that's the same
situation you would be if you bought a
house and it somehow had a magic you
know wish-granting room in it you
wouldn't exactly know how it works until
you know they experiment and they find
out some of the rules and the parameters
but because they can't foresee the
consequences of some of the wishes that
they
make yeah it's really most of the movies
about that one wish that they made yeah
I think they shouldn't have done that I
think they should have made that wish
resolved it earlier and then made
another couple other [ __ ] up with that
they had to solve in the movie you know
I mean yeah I think there I think that's
what I was saying I was kind of
frustrated I think they could have done
a little bit more with this with the
premise yeah with the premise instead of
getting hung up on that one problem they
should have solved that problem within
about 10 minutes and then had two more
problems like that one focus on because
it seemed like that one wish that they
made had so many it was like dominoes
falling down it had like all these other
unforeseen circumstances and it also
opened up more possibilities of you know
now the parameters of the room they
thought they knew what they were but now
they don't because you know there's
other factors at play it's kind of like
a horror version of [ __ ] Back to the
Future where they realize they got that
they got the time machine but in part
two they realize you can [ __ ] up the
timestream yeah alternate you don't know
that's going on you just have to see it
for yourself and the things that mean is
one of those movies where like I said
there was I there was not a lot of
reviews on this that I that I kind of
you know tried to research but there's
one guy on there and I can't remember
the name of the channel is but he did
like it's called cinema something but he
like explained the movie and one of the
things that he said about the end I'm
like oh yeah [ __ ] I didn't realize that
and then I was reading like all the
comments and like this is one of those
movies that you really should probably
see it a second time or maybe a third
time because there's a lot of different
possibilities right um for what the
ending might have meant it's not that
it's one of those frustrating oh it's an
ambiguous ending or anything there's two
for my point of view there's two
distinct possibilities for what the
ending could mean and both of them are
kind of messed up so and like I said we
before we started recording I was like
god we've really should spoil this
because it's really hard to talk about
if you can't spoil it and there's like
so much [ __ ] that I wanted to talk about
about that's why I just happy but I
think it's better to have people see it
I definitely
definitely recommend this movie if you
really like kind of like mind bender
type of movies yeah you know or Twilight
Zone II kind of movies where they'll
just imagine what would happen if you
moved into a house and you found a
hidden room in there and a key to that
hidden room and that room fulfilled
oh damn wishes and all you have to do is
go in there and say I want a million
dollars and then a million dollars I
want a Rembrandt just and then just what
what kind of [ __ ] would you start
wishing for yeah and that's the movies
about yeah but like I said if they wish
for something which it probably wasn't a
good idea but I can see why they did it
yeah because there is a justification
for why they did it and then like the
fact that they made this one particular
wish yes yes yeah it's just like makes
everything go more and more sucked up is
the movie again oh you know if you were
a single man you go in there and you
start [ __ ] wishing for [ __ ] babes
just just watch that might go wrong also
this movies that with girls maybe that
would go track that would go wrong but I
feel like even wishing for objects I
think there would come a point because
early on in the movie I kind of thought
it was going to go the direction of oh
well if you can just wish for whatever
you want then nothing has any value
which is not exactly the direction that
it went it went like in a direction that
I didn't exactly expect you know what I
mean yes I'd have like 200 bigger
questions that I was they don't know
they don't know what we're talking about
but oh if that's what it was
yeah they might have just been a
holodeck it's possible yeah but like I
said there's a lot of different
possibilities so if you have shudder
which you know if you're a horror fan
you probably should get it they didn't
pay me for that plug I just really like
shudder but they just recently added it
it doesn't seem like it's gotten a lot
of press although a lot of the horror
festivals in Europe and Europe it showed
a lot over there and that seems to be
getting really positive reviews over
there so definitely check it out if you
like these kind of like Mindbender
Twilight Zone monkey's paw type of
what-if scenario movies because it
definitely goes in some messed-up
directions and if you do see it like
message me cuz I want to like talk to
somebody about this without you spoiling
it for everybody you know what I'm
saying so yeah definitely check this one
[Music]